We are following breaking news
out of Japan this morning.
A powerful earthquake measuring 7.5
has triggered evacuations
and a tsunami warning.
You're looking at the moment
the quake struck.
Video from along the coast.
There you can see the shaking.
It went on for some time.
Here is more video
from the Ishikawa Prefecture in Japan.
The population
there is about a million people.
This is
on the western coast of Japan,
about 185 miles from Tokyo.
Again, from this footage,
you can see
just how long this shaking went on for.
You can see the poles there on the left
starting to sway.
Ultimately,
this did lead to some building collapses.
And shortly you'll see dust rising
from the collapsed building there
on the left side of your screen.
Again, very powerful shaking
felt by millions of people,
about a million people or so
in the more severe area
where this earthquake struck.
Japanese officials
have now lowered
their tsunami alert
from a major tsunami warning.
It is now a tsunami warning, period.
They could expect waves of up to ten
feet there.
And the aftershocks there
warning could last days.
We are getting new video
from inside a parking garage
you can see here
these cars just shaking there inside this
this solid structure.
Again, you get a sense of the power
of this earthquake.
We have team coverage this morning.
Derek Van
Dam is tracking the tsunami threat.
We're going to start
with Hanako Montgomery,
who is live in Tokyo.
Give us the latest from there.
Yeah, good morning, John.
So right now, as you mentioned,
the tsunami warning has been lowered.
We're still expecting to see
ten feet of waves, though.
So still very, very frightening
and daunting
for many people
living in Ishikawa Prefecture.
Just to note some of the damage
that we've been seeing.
At least.
33,000 homes have lost power.
Others have collapsed.
We're seeing reports of people
being trapped under their homes.
As well.
We're also knowing that about a thousand
self-defense force
personnel have been dispatched
and they're trying to confirm
any of the survivors
in Ishikawa Prefecture.
We also know that 20 self-defense force
planes and also other vessels
are trying to confirm
just the extent of this damage.
So this powerful, powerful earthquake,
you know,
was also a shallow earthquake,
which is very significant to note,
because with shallow earthquakes,
they can actually trigger very powerful
and destructive tsunamis,
even though the tsunami level
has been dropped down
to just a tsunami warning,
we are still expecting to see large waves
coming out of the western
part of Japan, John Hanako
I think everyone in everyone's
memories are
what happened in 2011 in Japan
with the powerful earthquake there
and the destruction of the Fukushima
nuclear power plant.
Any concerns this morning
as the morning or the evening develops
in Japan
about things like that, power
plants and nuclear power
Yeah, John.
So we're
getting information from the
from the Japanese government
that there are currently
no nuclear abnormalities
at any of the nuclear
power plants close to the epicenter
near Ishikawa Prefecture.
However, of course, this moment,
this terrible,
terrible moment
in Japanese history, the 2011 earthquake
and tsunami is very present
in many people's minds.
Today is New Year's Day here in Japan,
when many people are celebrating
with their families,
with their friends at home,
and suddenly
their TVs are telling them
to evacuate to get to higher ground.
And just a very frightening moment
for many people in the country,
specifically on western Japan, that coast
where you actually don't
historically see
very many earthquakes of this size.
So, again,
just a lot of
scared feelings
and just a lot of tension right now
to see what kind of damage
this subsequent tsunami
could bring to western Japan. John.
Frayed nerves in the region, to be sure.
Hanako Montgomery, keep us posted
throughout the rest of the morning.
Well,
this now is meteorologist
Derek Van Dam,
who was following the tsunami threat.
Derek, what are you seeing?
Yeah, well,
I mean,
just seeing video of this stirs
up emotions from 2011
when I covered the tsunami
that reached the East Coast of Japan.
But this is some of the latest video of
the tsunami wave
that reached the western shorelines
of the Honshu Honshu region.
So we're
looking at
a tsunami wave
traveling up to Saiki River
in a town called Jitsu.
It's got a population
of about 200,000 people
and this wave height that we're seeing,
this is some new video
so we're getting it as it comes.
Telling you and analyzing it in real time
really fits the narrative
of some of the observed
tsunami wave heights
that we have experienced and seen
along those Western Bay
and shorelines of western Japan.
The tsunami warning
as compared to
what was a major tsunami warning
from the Japan Meteorological Agency.
There's a difference.
The major tsunami warning
was waves up to five meters
or roughly 16 feet.
Now with a tsunami warning,
that downgrade,
that means waves up to three meters.
That's roughly ten feet.
So that's still possible within this area
highlighted in red
but tsunami advisories
stretch the entire coastline
as far north as Hokkaido.
And then just looking at the basic
geometry of this area,
here's the Korean Peninsula.
Here's Russia.
There is nothing
preventing the sloshing effect
to take place
from such a magnitude,
such a powerful earthquake
near this Ishikawa Prefecture.
To propagate
that wave slosh back and forth.
And that is why we have
these tsunami warnings
that are ongoing several hours
after that initial initial earthquake
that struck.
Here's a look
at some of those observed wave heights.
You can see
matching that
narrative of about four feet in height
for some of those locations.
And really,
what's happening
here is the fact
that this was such a shallow earthquake.
It was about
roughly ten
kilometers
or six miles underground
under the sea floor.
And that displaced the water,
forcing a wave
at the surface of the ocean.
And some of the boys
within this area,
just off the west
coast of Japan, measured
a one meter
observed tsunami heights
far away from the coastline.
And that's significant
because that means that just basic
bathymetry, bathymetry
shows us
that the natural curve of the coastline
as it edges
closer to the population density.
That wave has nowhere to go but up.
And that is why
they initially projected this
five meter potential tsunami wave threat
waves up to 16 feet.
Now they're starting
to get more information
where communication is lacking
because of the lack of power
and communication lines.
And there have downgraded that
to a tsunami warning.
So waves potentially upwards of ten feet.
But nonetheless, John,
this was a powerful earthquake.
We expect the aftershocks to continue.
In fact,
50 million people felt some sort
of shaking from this particular event.
And there have already been over 15
aftershocks reported in
and around this part of Japan.
As you said,
millions and millions of people
did feel the effects of this earthquake,
which measured 7.5.
It happened
on the western coast of Japan,
which is not one of the areas
that I think
we're really used to seeing earthquakes
in Japan.
This threat that you're talking about.
How long will it go on for Derek?
When will people there
breathe a sigh of relief?
Well, in
terms of the shaking,
so let's talk about aftershocks.
This is just going off
of previous earthquakes
with similar magnitudes.
We have aftershocks
that can last for hours, days,
even weeks after the initial mega two
earthquake, a 7.5 earthquake
in the way that's broken down
because this is a level of magnitude
depending on
how far you go back in terms of power
and strength of the actual earthquake.
So on average,
with a quake of 7.5, originally,
we have at least one
earthquake, an aftershock,
I should say, of 6.5 or greater
And typically with this scenario,
we also experience
a ten or so aftershocks of magnitude 5.5
or higher.
So putting this all together,
you got to think about the type
of construction
that houses, the homes,
the apartment complexes in this area.
It is a mixture of concrete
and some of the more sturdier earthquake
susceptible areas, but
also some buildings and structures
could be made out of wood.
So they have been destabilized.
So initial aftershock rocks
could potentially take down.
Those buildings are easier
than it would be
with the original earthquake.
And then we got to think about
just the natural curvature
of the Ishikawa Prefecture
with the magnitude
7.5 earthquake occurring just offshore.
That is going to wrap around waves
and that's going to splash
in between
these blue bays
and coastline that face west across
this area.
Know these aftershocks.
That can be unnerving
for people who are,
I think, already
vulnerable there,
but also extremely dangerous
given what just happened
with this very powerful earthquake.
Derek Van
Dam was watching this very closely
for us.
Keep us posted.
We'll check back in with you in a bit.
We are getting some new video
just in where you can see
the power of this earthquake.
This from inside a home where you can see
that baby
sitting there just going back and forth
and back and forth.
Not to mention
what's on the TV screen there.
You could see out the window.
It's a 7.5
magnitude earthquake
hitting Japan on New Year's Day.